>> Sandra: DR. ANTHONY FAUCI
SAYS HE KNOWS AMERICANS ARE DONE
WITH COVID RESTRICTIONS BUT IT
DOESN’T MATTER.
>> John: SAYING FOLKS NEED TO BE
READY FOR THEM TO RETURN BECAUSE
CASES OF A NEW STRAIN ARE COVID
ARE ON THE RISE.
>> Sandra: I’M SURE PEOPLE ARE
HAPPY TO HEAR ALL THIS.
BRING IN RAND PAUL.
SENATOR, GREAT TO HAVE YOU HERE
AND GOOD TO SEE YOU.
I FEEL LIKE WE JUST TEED YOU UP.
WE KNOW WHERE YOU STAND ON DR.
ANTHONY FAUCI, YOU HAVE CALLED
FOR HIS RESIGNATION AND BEYOND.
IS THERE ANY TOLERANCE FOR MORE
RESTRICTIONS IF WE SEE CASES
RISE?
>> WELL, THIS SHOULD COME AS A
SHOCK TO NO ONE THAT ANTHONY
FAUCI IS ONCE AGAIN
MISUNDERSTANDING,
MISINTERPRETING THE DATA.
WE HAVE A LOWER INCIDENCE NOW
SINCE THE BEGINNING OF THE
PANDEMIC, LOWER DEATH RATE,
HOSPITALIZATION RATE, AND HE’S
FLAT OUT WRONG AND WHEN WE
SHOULD BE TALKING ABOUT IF YOU
DO GET IT OR SUSCEPTIBLE, IN
YOUR 80s OR 70s AND YOUR SPOUSE
GETS IT THERE IS A TREATMENT BUT
ALL OF THE TREATMENTS WORK BEST
IF YOU ARE TREATED EARLY BEFORE
YOUR SYMPTOMS GET TOO BAD.
SO, ANTHONY FAUCI WILL NOT TELL
YOU THIS BUT I WILL.
MONO CLONAL ANTIBODIES ARE
ENORMOUSLY SUCCESSFUL.
BUT IF YOU WAIT UNTIL YOU ARE
SICK ENOUGH TO GO TO THE
HOSPITAL, ANTHONY FAUCI AND THE
GOVERNMENT DOCTORS HAVE DICTATED
YOU CANNOT GET THE ANTIBODIES AS
AN INPATIENT.
IT’S A REAL TRAGEDY BUT THERE
ARE TREATMENTS AND PEOPLE NEED
TO KNOW WHAT THE TREATMENTS ARE.
THE GOOD NEWS IS, THE PANDEMIC
IS ON THE WAY, LOWER INCIDENTS,
LOWER HOSPITALIZATIONS, LOWER
DEATH RATE SINCE THE BEGINNING
OF THE PANDEMIC.
>> John: MANY PEOPLE MAY NOT
BELIEVE ANTHONY FAUCI IS TALKING
ABOUT THAT, ROLL THE TAPE BACK.
>> I DON’T THINK THERE’S MUCH
STOMACH FOR PEOPLE TO ALL OF A
SUDDEN TURN AROUND EVEN IF THERE
IS AN UPTICK.
I THINK THERE IS GOING TO BE A
LOT OF INERTIA, IF NOT ACTIVE
PUSHBACK IN PEOPLE IF IT IS
REQUIRED TO INCREASE OR GO BACK
TO SOME OF THE MITIGATION.
SO THE ADVICE IS PROCEED WITH
LIFE AS NORMAL AS YOU POSSIBLY
CAN, BUT BE PREPARED THAT WE
MIGHT NEED TO MAKE MODIFICATIONS
IF THINGS CHANGE.
>> John: NOT MUCH STOMACH TO GO
BACK, I CAN IMAGINE PEOPLE WITH
PITCH FORKS COMING OVER THE
HILL.
>> IF YOU BELIEVE IN DR. FAUCI
WHAT YOU SHOULD DO IS GET
STICKERS AND MAKE SURE THEY ARE
ON THE FLOOR, AND A YARD STICK
SO YOU KNOW YOU ARE SIX FEET
AWAY FROM PEOPLE.
AND PLEXIGLASS, CARRY PLEXIGLASS
AROUND WITH YOU, BECAUSE DR.
FAUCI THINKS IT SOMEHOW, YOU
KNOW, REFLECTS THE VIRUS AWAY
FROM YOU.
NOT ONE THING HE HAS ADVOCATED
HAS WORKED.
AND I’M NOT AGAINST THE VACCINE.
IF YOU TAKE A SAMPLE OF BLOOD OF
1,000 PEOPLE IN THE UNITED
STATES, ANTIBODIES TO THE VIRUS
OR THE VACCINE, IT’S OVER 95%.
THAT’S WHY WE ARE DOING BETTER
WITH THIS.
WE HAVE DEVELOPED IMMUNITY FROM
HAVING THE DISEASE OR VACCINATED
AND THAT’S WHY WE ARE DOING
BETTER IN ADDITION TO THE FABT
THE VIRUS HAS MUTATED TO A
DEADLY FORM BUT HE WON’T ADMIT
IT, HE’S CAUGHT UP PUTTING
STICKERS ON YOUR FLOOR, ON YOU,
THE GUY IS A MENACE AND NOT
RIGHT SINCE ANYTHING SINCE THE
START OF THIS.
>> Sandra: YOU ALWAYS TELL US
WHAT YOU FEEL, AND WHAT YOU ARE
SAYING IS BACKED UP BY THE
LATEST JOHNS HOPKINS UNIVERSITY,
FOUND LOCKDOWNS HAD LITTLE TO NO
IMPACT IN REDUCING FATALITY
DURING THE SPRING OF 2020.
CONCLUDED THE LOCKDOWNS WERE ILL
FOUNDED AND INSTEAD LARGE
ECONOMIC AND SOCIAL COST WHERE
THEY HAD BEEN ADOPTED.
SO, HOW IS IT BASED ON THAT
SCIENCE THAT WE CAN EVEN BE
CONSIDERING THIS, OR TALKING
ABOUT RESTRICTIONS EVEN IF THIS
IS A WORSE CASE SCENARIO AND
CASES DO INDEED SPIKE?
>> THE REASON WE ARE IN THIS
SITUATION IS BECAUSE WE HAVE
ALLOWED A CENTRAL PLANNER, DR.
FAUCI, TO BE IN CHARGE OF
EVERYTHING.
IN A FREE SOCIETY, EVERYONE IS
IN CHARGE OF THEIR OWN
HEALTHCARE, YOU GO TO DOCTORS
UNTIL YOU FIND A DOCTOR THAT YOU
THINK HAS AN OPINION THAT IS
VALID, AND YOU GET YOUR CHOICE.
IF DR. FAUCI WERE A FAMILY
DOCTOR IN PEORIA, HE WOULD ONLY
BE DAMAGING THE PEOPLE SILLY
ENOUGH TO SEE HIM AS A DOCTOR.
BUT BECAUSE HE’S EMPLOYED BY THE
GOVERNMENT AND HIS DICTATES GO
DOWN THROUGHOUT THE SYSTEM, AS
HE MAKES ERRORS THEY ARE
PROMULGATED EVERYWHERE.
HIS BIGGEST ERROR IS PESSIMISM.
SHAKING AND RINGING HIS HANDS,
WE KNOW IT’S COMING BACK AND YOU
HAVE TO STAY INSIDE,
SHELTER-IN-PLACE.
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE OF THAT.
THE EVIDENCE IS WE ARE GETTING
BETTER, AND FOR THOSE WHO DO GET
SICK, THE MAIN THING HE SHOULD
BE TELLING YOU, HE’S NOT TELLING
YOU, IS THERE IS TREATMENT.
SOONER YOU GET THE TREATMENT THE
BETTER.
IF YOU WERE 80 YEARS OLD AND
YOUR SPOUSE HAS COVID, YOU CAN
GET TREATMENT WITH NO SYMPTOMS
AND WITH NO POSITIVE TEST.
THAT’S HOW GOOD THE TREATMENT
IS.
AND THAT’S WHAT THEY DO FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE AT HIGH RISK.
BUT HE’S NOT TELLING YOU ANY OF
THAT.
JUST SAYING OH, WE NEED TO
VACCINATE NEWBORNS, WHICH IS
UNTRUE AND NOT SUPPORTED BY THE
SCIENCE.
>> Sandra: HAVE NOT EVEN TAKEN
THE MASKS OFF THE TODDLERS HERE
IN MANHATTAN.
NEW YORK, IF YOU’VE GOT CHILDREN
UNDER FIVE, THEY ARE STILL
REQUIRED TO WEAR A MASK TO BE IN
SCHOOLS AND DAYCARE CENTERS.
>> THE DEATH RATE FOR CHILDREN
UNDER 15 IS ONE IN 2.32 MILLION,
LESS THAN ONE IN A MILLION.
THAT’S A DEATH RATE.
NO REASON FOR ANY CHILD IN
AMERICA TO BE IN A MASK.
SWEDEN THEY WOULD ARE NO MASKS
AND NO CHILDREN DIED.
>> John: TIME IS GROWING SHORT
HERE BUT YOU WROTE ABOUT THIS,
THE WHITE HOUSE CONTINUES TO
INSIST THAT INFLATION WILL BEGIN
TO MITIGATE LATER ON THIS YEAR.
JEROME POWELL, BEGINNING TO
RAISE INTEREST RATES SAYS 2 TO 3
YEARS.
WHAT’S THE INFLATION OUTLOOK TO
YOU?
>> WELL, CERTAINLY IS NOT
TRANSITORY ANYMORE, THEY EXCEPT
TELLING US IT’S TRANSITORY.
TO MY MIND THREE YEARS IS NOT
TRANSITORY.
BUT YOU CANNOT FIX INFLATION
UNLESS YOU KNOW WHAT CAUSES IT.
IT’S CAUSED BY DEBT, DEFICIT
SPENDING AND THE FEDERAL RESERVE
PRINTING UP NEW MONEY TO BUY THE
DEBT.
THAT’S WHERE INFLATION COMES
FROM.
SO THE MORE DEBT, THE MORE
INFLATION.
PAYING THE BILLS OF 6 TRILLION
WORTH OF DEBT, BOTH PARTIES ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR IT, REPUBLICANS
AND DEMOCRATS, BUT THE ANSWER IS
NOT ADDING MORE DEBT, THE ANSWER
IS MORE FISCALLY RESPONSIBLE AND
I DON’T KNOW OF A DEMOCRAT IN
WASHINGTON IN CONGRESS THAT IS
PROMOTING ANY --
>> Sandra: I HAVE THE ECON PANEL
COMING UP, I’LL USE WHAT YOU SAY
NOW WITH THEM.
WOULD YOU BE IN FAVOR OF A
VOLKER STYLE ADDRESSING OF THE
INFLATION SITUATION RIGHT NOW
THAT WE SAW IN THE 1980S WHERE
HE TACKLES IT SO SEVERELY THAT
THERE WAS MAJOR ECONOMIC
CONSEQUENCES SHORT-TERM INTEREST
RATES, SHORT-TERM SPIKED ABOVE
20%, HOUSES WERE NOT SELLING,
CARS WERE NOT SELLING, BUT IT
FIXED THE PROBLEM OF THE 1970S.
WOULD YOU BE IN FAVOR OF THAT
AGGRESSIVE APPROACH FOR JAY
POWELL?
>> WHAT I WILL SAY, DON’T ADD
MORE TO YOUR DEBT.
TRY TO BALANCE THE BUDGET OR
CLOSER TO BALANCE.
AS FAR AS INTEREST RATES, I SAW
A STATISTIC I THOUGHT WAS
INTERESTING.
OVER THE AVERAGE OF THE LAST 50
YEARS, THE FEDERAL RESERVE’S
DISCOUNT RATE HAS BEEN A POINT
ABOVE INFLATION.
RIGHT NOW IT’S EIGHT POINTS
BELOW INFLATION.
SO YOU HAVE NEGATIVE INTEREST
RATES.
SORT OF LIKE FREE MONEY.
8% INFLATION, BORROW FOR 2, 3%,
YEAH, WHY NOT JUST KEEP
BORROWING MONEY.
WE ARE IN A SITUATION THAT’S
INFLATIONARY, AND IT’S A
TECHNICAL QUESTION AND I’M NOT
SURE I HAVE THE ANSWER.
BUT I HAVE THE ANSWER, YOU
SHOULD NOT HAVE INTEREST RATES
THAT ARE NEGATIVE AND SHOULD NOT
HAVE INTEREST RATES BELOW
INFLATION AND THAT’S WHAT WE
HAVE NOW.